[Música]
un banquero de Londres envía la mása
reciente información accionaria a sus
colegas en Hong Kong en menos de un
segundo con un solo clic un cliente en
Nueva York compra un aparato electrónico
hecho en Pekín que es transportado a
través del océano en cuestión de días
por avión de carga o buque Porta
contenedores la velocidad y el volumen
en los que los bienes y la información
se mueven a través del mundo de hoy no
tienen precedentes en la historia pero
el intercambio global es más antiguo de
lo que creemos se remonta a más de 2,000
años en un tramo de más de 8,000 km
conocido como la ruta de la seda la ruta
de la seda no era en realidad un solo
camino sino una red de múltiples rutas
que surgieron gradualmente a lo largo de
siglos conectando a diversos
asentamientos entre sí ebra por hebra
las primeras civilizaciones agrícolas
estuvieron aisladas en los valles
fértiles de ríos y la geografía
circundante y el miedo a lo desconocido
les impedía viajar Pero a medida que
crecieron descubrieron que los áridos
desiertos y los pasos en sus fronteras
estaban habitados no por los demonios
del folklore sino por tribus nómadas a
caballo los citas que iban desde Hungría
a mongolia habían entrado en contacto
con las civilizaciones de Grecia Egipto
India y China estos encuentros eran a
menudo menos que pacíficos pero incluso
a través de las incursiones y la guerra
y del comercio y la protección de los
comerciantes viajeros a cambio de un
pago los nómadas comenzaron a propagar
bienes ideas y tecnologías entre
culturas que no tenían contacto directo
uno de los hilos más importantes de esta
creciente fue el camino real persa
terminado por Darío io en el siglo V
antes de Cristo con una extensión de más
de 3,000 km del río Tigris hasta el mar
ejeo sus puntos de relevo permitían a
bienes y mensajes viajar en casi un
décimo del tiempo del que le tomaría un
viajero individual con la conquista de
Persia por parte de Alejandro Magno y la
expansión hacia Asia central a través de
la captura de ciudades como samarcanda y
el establecimiento de otras nuevas como
Alejandría escate la red de cultura y
comercio egipcio persa griego e indio se
extendió más al oriente como nunca antes
sentando las bases de un puente entre
China y occidente esto se hizo realidad
en el siglo II antes de Cristo cuando un
embajador llamado shen xiang fue enviado
a negociar con los nómadas en el
occidente y regresó al emperador han con
historias de civilizaciones sofisticadas
comercio próspero y mercancías exóticas
Más allá de las fronteras occidentales
se enviaron Embajadores y comerciantes
hacia Persia e India para comerciar seda
Y Jade por caballos y algodón junto con
ejércitos para asegurar su paso las
rutas orientales y occidentales
gradualmente se unieron entre Sí en un
sistema integrado que abarcaba eurasia
lo cual permitía el intercambio cultural
y comercial más lejos Que nunca los
productos chinos llegaron a Roma y
ocasionaron un flujo saliente de oro que
llevó a la prohibición de la seda
mientras que la cristalería romana era
muy apreciada en China las expediciones
militares en Asia central también dieron
lugar a encuentros entre soldados chinos
y romanos posiblemente Incluso se
transmitió la tecnología de la ballesta
al mundo occidental la dem banda de
bienes exóticos y extranjeros y las
utilidades que trajeron mantuvo las
cebras de la ruta de la seda intactas
aún cuando el Imperio Romano se
desintegró y las dinastías chinas
florecieron y decayeron incluso las
hordas mongolas conocidas por el pillaje
y el saqueo protegían activamente las
rutas comerciales en lugar de
interrumpirlos con las materias primas
estas rutas también permitieron el
movimiento de las tradiciones las
innovaciones las ideologías y los
idiomas originario de la India el
budismo emigró a China y Japón para
convertir En la religión dominante allí
el islam se extendió por la Península
arábica en el sur de Asia mezclándose
con las creencias nativas y dando lugar
a nuevas religiones como el sijismo
además la pólvora llegó desde china a
Oriente medio para forjar el futuro de
los imperios otomanos safávida y mongol
en cierto modo el éxito de la ruta de la
seda condujo a su propio colapso al
llegar a Europa las nuevas tecnologías
marítimas como la brújula con la cual
las largas rutas terrestres Se volvieron
obsoletas Mientras tanto el colapso del
gobierno mongol fue seguido por La
retirada de China del comercio
internacional pero a pesar de que las
antiguas rutas y redes no duraron habían
cambiado el mundo para siempre y no
había vuelta atrás los europeos en busca
de nuevas rutas marítimas a las riquezas
que sabían que les esperaban en Asia
Oriental llevaron a la era de la
exploración y la expansión hacia África
y las Américas en la actualidad la
interconexión global da forma a nuestras
vidas como nunca antes los compradores
canadienses compran camisetas hechas en
bangladesh el público japonés ve
programas de la televisión británica y
los tunecinos utilizan software
estadounidense para lanzar una
Revolución el impacto de la
globalización sobre la cultura y la
economía es indiscutible pero
independientemente de sus ventajas y
desventajas está lejos de ser un
fenómeno nuevo y a pesar de que las
montañas los desiertos y los océanos una
vez nos separaron Ahora son eludido
mediante vehículos Supersónicos cables
de comunicación intercontinentales y
señales que se irradian a través del
espacio en lugar de las caravanas que
viajaban por meses nada de esto hubiera
sido posible sin las culturas pioneras
cuyos esfuerzos crearon la ruta de la
seda la primera red Mundial de la
historia si te encanta aprender
suscríbete a nuestro canal publicamos
nuevos videos sobre todo tipo de temas
desde la historia del mundo según los
gatos hasta lo que supondría vivir en la
luna mantente conectado y
curioso